إنه لغز وهذا يضع
الكثير من العبء على عاتقنا جميعًا حيث
يبحث الجميع عن المعلومات
تمامًا كما نعتقد أنهم يعتقدون أن لدينا
إجابات للأسف لم نكن عبد
الله معها وقد سمعنا من الحكومة التركية
أن  قالوا إنهم
يعتقدون أن والدك
دخل القنصلية وأنه تعرض للاختناق
وأنه قُتل بعد ذلك من قبل
الحكومة السعودية ، ونحن نفهم أنه
قُتل حتى الآن ، إنها غامضة
مثل القصة مثل تفاصيل ما
حدث بالضبط في الداخل  كما تعلم ، كيف
يقوم كل من وسائل الإعلام على Twitter TV
بعمل قصة مختلفة
وبالنسبة لي أحاول تبسيط الأمر
قدر الإمكان أنه مات نعم
وأفترض أنني كنت أعرف آخر
طفل من أبناء والدك.
رأيته ، لقد رأيته قبل شهرين في تركيا ،
كيف كان ، ثم كان سعيدًا ، نعم
كان الأمر أشبه بفرصة جيدة جدًا
بالنسبة لي لرؤيته ونحن نتسكع في
جميع أنحاء اسطنبول ، لقد استمتعنا وأعتقد أنني
كنت محظوظًا حقًا  في تلك
اللحظة الأخيرة معه ، كيف لم يكن الأمر دائمًا
على أسرتك على والدتك
وأخواتك ، إنه أمر صعب الحظ ،
ليس من السهل ، خاصة في التدمير
الكبير ، إنه ليس سهلاً ، إنه مربك
حتى الطريقة التي نحزن بها ، إنه مربك بعض الشيء
مثل  لأننا نحزن
في نفس الوقت الذي ننظر فيه إلى وسائل الإعلام
والمعلومات المضللة كأن هناك
الكثير من الصعود والهبوط ، إنه ليس وضعًا طبيعيًا
كما لو أنه ليس
قرصًا عاديًا على الإطلاق ما
نريده الآن هو
-  أفضل له داخل
المدينة المنورة والعودة إليه مع شاهد عائلته في
المملكة العربية السعودية في المملكة العربية السعودية نعم لقد
تحدثت مع أنني تحدثت عن ذلك
مع بعض السلطات
وآمل أن يحدث ذلك قريبًا ولكن عليك
أن تجد شخصًا ما يحتاج  للعثور على جسده ،
نعم أعتقد أن البحث مستمر
ومتفائل حقًا بشأن ذلك ، لكن
ما الذي تعلقه على آمالك وهو
تقليد إسلامي ليس فقط إسلاميًا
، إنه قضية إنسانية أساسية
نحتاج فقط للتأكد من ذلك  هناك بعض
السلام حتى الآن قلت لا أستطيع أن أصدق
أنه مات
، وأنا أعلم أنني أعني أنه لم يغرق
مرة أخرى معي عاطفياً لقد
مات بالتأكيد ، لكن
العبء العاطفي الذي يأتي مع
اللغز هو في الواقع عبء كبير حقًا